bienvenidos desde programa especial de
fin de año sobre chile y el legado de
sebastián piñera el segundo mandato del
centroderechista sebastián piñera
llegará a su fin en marzo sin embargo
cuando el multimillonario empresario
asumió su segunda presidencia en 2018 de
manos de michelle bachelet chile era un
país muy diferente la preocupación en
este momento era recuperar una economía
estancada la lucha por una educación
gratuita y un incipiente problema de
inmigración el estallido de la revuelta
social de octubre de 2019 ha ocurrido
tan sólo un año y medio después de que
piñera subiera al poder tiro por tierra
las aspiraciones de su gobierno y se
convirtió en uno de los eventos que ha
transformado más profundamente la
sociedad chilena desde el fin de la
dictadura durante meses el país ardió
literalmente expresando las demandas y
el descontento de una ciudadanía
contenido durante varias décadas que
solicitaban mejor educación pensiones y
salud entre otros tan solo la pandemia y
el 'toque de queda' permitió al gobierno
controlar una situación que durante
meses fue incontrolable
repasamos en el siguiente reportaje
alguno de los aspectos positivos y
negativos que deja el legado de
sebastián piñera
víctimas de violencia de estado la
coordinadora de víctimas de trauma
ocular del estallido de octubre del 2019
que agrupa a 100 de los más de 450
damnificados ocupa en forma de protesta
uno de los edificios del hospital del
programa estatal diseñado para ellos del
que acusan graves falencias
todo lo que nosotros no nos ponen como
reparación
una noticia crítica
claramente sin un buen tratamiento
psicológico electrónico aún más
y hoy pongo ahora puedo decir de hecho
me gustó no habrá pasado porque es
idéntica mejor no sé menos pero el
estado puso estas prótesis para gustarle
visión porque la gente no vea que tantos
jóvenes en la calle sin un ojo demandan
tratamientos psicológicos y personal
especializado en violaciones a los
derechos humanos ninguno de ellos más de
dos años después ha recibido justicia o
compensación económica
para que levante su protesta reclaman
una ley de reparación de todas las
víctimas de violaciones de derechos
humanos del estallido la que la fiscalía
llegó a tener más de 8 mil denuncias
dolor mucho dolor
psicológicamente fue tremendo porque yo
no puede seguir trabajando en lo que
hacía me afecta todavía acordarme de eso
es terrible
psicológicamente no ha afectado no
solamente nosotros también pero también
a nuestras familias hay un abandono
total de parte del estado con todas las
víctimas de violaciones de derechos
humanos por el terrorismo estado lo que
estamos sufriendo nosotros acá
[Música]
se convierte en el octavo país en la
región en aprobar el matrimonio
igualitario una ley que cambia muchas
vidas así como
[Música]
y
más para nosotros que un cambio creo que
cualquiera de
nosotros es algo pero gigante maria jose
y no oculta su emoción nadie predijo al
comienzo del gobierno de sebastián
piñera que el matrimonio igualitario al
que el centroderechista se mostró
contrario en el pasado sería parte
positiva de su legado junto a una buena
vacunación contra la comida un legado
ensombrecido no obstante por las
violaciones a los derechos humanos
ocurridas durante su mandato que
volvieron a reabrir en la sociedad
chilena heridas de la dictadura que
nunca se cerraron del todo con piñera
termina un ciclo de larga energía
institucional post dictadura los años de
la concertación de centroizquierda el
show alternancia con la centroderecha el
nuevo presidente heredará un país con
altas tasas de vacunación y dosis de
refuerzo en el que chile se sitúa en la
cabeza mundial pero tendrá una misión
complicada la de restablecer la
estabilidad y el orden público en un
país que encadena las consecuencias del
estallido y la pandemia y sus costos
económicos un alto endeudamiento y tasas
de inflación
en el segundo país de la región con un
mayor porcentaje de este colectivo según
la onu una cifra que se incrementó en
2021 con el flujo constante de
inmigrantes en el norte será un tema
clave para el nuevo presidente la
relación con la convención
constitucional que se encuentra en este
momento debatiendo los contenidos de una
nueva carta magna entre ellos los
mandatos y los poderes de un nuevo
presidente será también clave para
determinar la satisfacción de muchas de
las demandas expresadas en la revuelta
social aunque lo más difícil de todo
para el nuevo presidente será sin duda
lograr aprobar medidas legislativas en
un congreso completamente dividido es
decir garantizar la gobernabilidad y
evitar la vulnerabilidad política que
podría hacer que su mandato terminará
antes de tiempo algo que no ha ocurrido
nunca en la historia de la democracia
chilena